sure you can pull up an app and get
around Earth but directions in space are
a lot harder
our guide through the Stars is the Deep
Space Network a collection of antenna
arrays in California Australia and Spain
everything from student project
satellites to the new Horizons probe
meandering through the Kuiper belt
depends on it
to stay oriented an ultra precise atomic
clock on earth times how long it takes
for a signal to get from the network to
a spacecraft and back and navigators use
that to determine the crafts position
but here's the problem the deep space
network is basically hotel Wi-Fi too
many people are on it and it's pretty
slow once you get way out into space the
solution NASA is working to equip craft
with atomic clocks which will cut
calculation and transmission times in
half high bandwidth lasers can handle
photo and videos but as we send rockets
even further from Earth they'll need
their own navigation one plan is to
equip spacecraft with an autonomous
system that will gather images of nearby
objects and triangulate its position
sort of like GPS for a car but it'll be
called DPS deep-space positioning system